hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching god I'm gonna make
you a review you can't refuse did the
thing I'm nervous that I'm not going to
love this movie I'm nervous that it's
gonna be slow for me it's three hours
long this one right off the bat
interests me less because it's not based
on a true story it's based off of a book
though I like books I'm also nervous to
kind of cross this threshold of seeing
Godfather because this is like just such
a big one and it's been on the top of my
Tamara's never seen list for so long to
watch and just as a person list to to
watch and and now I'm doing it I feel
like I'm slowly chipping away at what
makes tamara tamara tamara hasn't seen
movies and now she has and that's such a
good thing and so I'm very excited in
that regard to to you know jump across
the line in the sand of never seeing
Godfather this is ally she's definitely
seeing Godfather
what has Tamara sees this is ridiculous
and so on and so forth let's watch The
Godfather
[Music]
you
do you want to know what my favorite
part was do you really want to know did
you get did you get horses that was so
cool the reveal was so cool wow this
guy's really confident for dealing with
these mob bosses and like these people
who are definitely gonna make his life
hell but he's still saying no to them
gift Johnny what's his name the part in
the movie you're so confident but and
then
oh you're sleeping in fat and there's
blood in your bed and then oh my god
that reveal how did you not wake up with
me what Horsehead okay initial thoughts
it was too long another initial time not
as exciting as Goodfellas which I
thought was gonna be the case and it was
the case I wasn't into it as much as
Goodfellas was it beautiful yes was it
just so time period II and awesome yes
was the acting crazy good yes
were there scenes that I did not care
about at all
yes yes yes yes yes this isn't movie
that is on book every movie reviewers
like top five best film effortless I've
heard about this movie my whole life
rightfully so it is oh well done there
were certain details like I mean I
noticed that when Vito was hit he he was
holding an orange than when he died he
was eating an orange oh that that must
be intentional things like that I
imagine I I missed a lot I was I said
when I noticed that while watching it
when he died The Godfather died oh I
probably missed a lot of
up until now okay but also I was born in
like a lot of points I don't know if
it's because I was expecting Goodfellas
and like non-stop action and when there
was action it was awesome
they were really few and far between
though and in a movie it's three hours
there's like a lot of talking sometimes
when a book is adapted into a movie they
cut out a bunch of stuff so that the
movie can be pasted properly and then
the people who read the book earlier
what what the heck you cut out my
favorite part when Jenkins jumped off
the bridge how'd you cut that up this I
feel like they kept everything in the
book how long is that is it as long as
Twilight all those okay it was less
about doing shady shit and selling drugs
and killing people and you know mob type
things you think about when you think of
mob things at least I do that was like
good those was completely what I thought
it should be in that regard this was way
more about just getting respect from
people being like a scary presence that
demands respect respect respect respect
obviously yes that really showed to me
in the pacing of it I know that the
pacing was absolutely intentional in
this death but yes I don't know I think
coming right off of Goodfellas this was
a little slow for me in some parts again
Horsehead scene invigorating Marlon
Brando playing Vito The Godfather
[Music]
that was brilliant this oh hell so good
Marlon Brando me powerhouse so good I
love his poison is just weird lip thing
that he does and the more prosthetics
for this that I didn't know about
watching videos after seeing this movie
about Marlon Brando and how the the
studio didn't want him to be in this
role is crazy to me because he was
amazing and then also learning that he
won the Oscar but denied it out of a
protest for how Native Americans were
represented on screen something that I
really quick saw in a video so I don't
know if that's actually 100% what it is
but very very interesting he was just so
compelling to watch and I really liked
Al Pacino in it and he clearly is
amazing but when it became more about
Michael filling in Vito's role I that's
when I started to really lose interest
Al Pacino right yeah okay and then we
get the Horsehead scene and it's amazing
I wore this in a video
once it has millions with you so I know
this horse head well I think the horse
head scene was my favorite part of the
movie
other than Marlon Brando's acting it
just caught me so off guard and it was
that thrilling feeling that I got from
Goodfellas so much that I just really
really enjoyed it and that's so like
2019 no attention span
I miss vine six-second videos millennial
miss of me to be like well when the
horse head was in the bed that was
exciting everything else is like snooze
you know not how I feel but it is pretty
telling you have a horse head to you was
my favorite Patton goes on and Vito gets
shot while picking up oranges at an
orange stand and I wrote no no no
there's no way the Godfather can do no
right he's such a dominant presence in
the beginning of the movie and I thought
the whole franchise that there just was
no way in my mind he was gonna die he
didn't then he does die a bit later on
and like I said I just I like it more
when he's in the forefront versus
Michael taking over though I do enjoy
watching Michael kind of rise the ring
didn't become a tough guy but I just
wanted Marlon Brando Michael shoots the
guys that shoot his dad goes into hiding
like
Vito's alive Tom is played by Robert
Duvall which I just realized in my notes
at this point I love Robert Duvall he's
in secondhand lions and I love them oh
hey you were meowing at me to be pets
making me an offer that I can't refuse
Marlin finds out that his son Sonny has
died and that performance is sho
flipping brilliant and award worthy and
it makes sense he won the award for Best
Actor and dang it what is it good that's
a theme that an actor goes and watches
before a touching audition or like a
hard difficult scene to shoot that is a
scene that you watch as an actor and go
WOW while doing this whole show a lot of
people have passed in the comments below
how I could be an actor without seeing
all of these movies and I mean it's
pretty easy I was a theatre actor before
moving to Chicago and quickly different
least now that I'm doing more film and
more commercial more on the screen
projects I understand that I didn't
really get that before it's like you
don't see me means to be an actor it's
theater theater which was valid for when
I was doing theater but now I gain so
many crucial things to see by doing this
show Val Kilmer and tombstone is
something that I will watch before like
any big audition that I have this scene
of Marlon Brando finding out that his
son has died perfect I think we get
three total make him an offer that you
can't refuse
two for Marlon Brando and then one from
Michael it's really what I was very
interested in another scene I really
really liked just because it was
a stark contrast from what was happening
on this side of the world and then what
was happening on the other side of the
world city I guess do you renounce Satan
bubble oh yeah don't you renounce Satan
sure sure sure but just like Monday and
Friday right do you renounce I know
[Music]
Michael kills his sister's husband
because he's beaten down on her Adrienne
just wait a few years girl you're gonna
meet Rocky right this is before rocky
Brent wait for years girl he's come the
love of your life he's gonna get you out
of this mob family and then well they're
still fighting it so you have a very
exciting life Michael's the new
Godfather things are bleak life is
terrible
Diane Keaton is morose and it's a long
great gorgeous clearly incredible movie
it's mom mom so long did they like it
yes did I like it as much as Goodfellas
for certain things yes but for other
things no this not being based on
something real lowers the stakes for me
though that's not the case when I watch
Iron Man but you know what I mean when
comparing two things so similar yeah it
kind comes into effect
I liked the characters being really
grounded in this it was beautiful the
acting was amazing Marlon Brando I also
don't think I've seen anything else
isn't the principal he's credited with
helping to popularize Stanislavski
system of acting
so going back to talking about theater
versus film that's something that I've
studied a lot in school that's really
cool really cool that he was an activist
it's really cool that he was very
handsome
just cool oh he played Stan Lee and a
streetcar named desire I've seen that I
am super curious about - I'm super
curious about how long it is thank you
so much for watching I will see you all
next week with The Godfather -
[Music]
[Applause]
you